let's talk about different kinds of work
okay let's talk about uh how you make
money in different kinds of work uh and
you know very few of us uh are
are lucky enough to
start out with anything other than
salary work we all start with salary
work you know
my first jobs was kind of an illegal
catering company uh in the back of a van
delivering indian food when i was you
know 15. that was my first like
organized job i had many jobs before
that i had paper routes you know i um i
washed dishes in the cafeterias so i've
done them all i've done i've done all
those jobs right so i've done salary
jobs and you have to start with shitty
salary jobs you got to work your way up
what helped me work my way up was i just
hated these jobs so i wanted to do
something better i want to do something
more intellectual
so i kind of earned my way up into
better and better and bigger jobs but it
was only when i got to silicon valley
that i got uh you know
educated on the the kind of the value of
owning a business and getting out of a
salary job right and so
that is super important like everybody
should aspire to that um so let me let
me see if i can come with a good a good
example right like let's talk about the
real estate business for a moment it's
like it's like a very real tangible
business right so the worst kind of job
is uh you know you're someone who's like
repairing a house you're like a
construction worker right so uh you know
maybe you get paid 10 bucks 15 bucks 20
an hour and you have to go to people's
houses need to go there at a specific
time you have to show up at 8 a.m and
your boss demands that you're there
and you kind of just repair little
pieces of the house right so here you
have zero leverage because it's just
whatever you're doing with your own
hands
you have you know you have some
accountability but not really your
accountability is to your boss it's not
to the ultimate client it's not to the
owner of the house
and you
you don't have any real specific
knowledge
the things that you're doing are you
know bear labor that almost anybody can
do
so you're just not going to get paid a
lot you're getting paid minimum wage
plus a little bit for your skill and
your time and depending on where you are
and that's kind of it
the next level up might be the
contractor right the general contractor
who's working on the house for the owner
um that person may be getting paid let's
call it fifty thousand dollars to do the
whole
thing and then they're paying the labor
fifteen dollars an hour and they're
keeping the difference
okay so that's obviously a better place
to be but how do we measure that how do
we know that's better well we know it's
better because this person has some
accountability right they have some
accountability because they're
responsible for the outcome so they have
to sweat it at night if things aren't
working right
and then they also have some leverage
and they have not a great formal
leverage but they have people working
for them that's the labor and they have
a little bit more specific knowledge and
that knowledge is how to organize a team
and make people show up on time and how
to deal with city regulations and those
kinds of things right
well the next level up from that
might be
a developer right now a developer is
someone who is going to actually go and
buy a crappy house and then they're
going to hire a bunch of contractors and
they're going to build that house and
they're probably going to take a loan to
buy the house they probably don't have
the money themselves they go to
investors they raise the money then they
buy the shell of a bad house they tear
down that house they rebuild it and they
sell it now a good developer could make
instead of fifty thousand dollars like
the general contractor or fifteen
dollars an hour like the laborer the
developer might be able to take a
million dollars or half a million
dollars in profit when they sell the
house for more than they bought it for
including the expense and the
construction but now notice what what's
required from the developer
very high level of accountability right
um so
by somebody just asked me and they've
already get taxed actually no very
simple answer to that is people like me
are highly globally mobile we leave uh
you know so
what what taxing capital does is it
causes capital flight taxing
entrepreneurs reduces entrepreneurs uh
you know the united states loss is
somebody else's gift so i'm not worried
about me i'm worried about my kids i'm
worried about the next generation who
wants the american dream to stay alive
anyway going back to my example
you know the developer
takes on more risk more accountability
has more leverage and needs to have more
specific knowledge they need to
understand fundraising they need to
understand the ins and outs of city
regulations they need to understand
where the real estate market is headed
and whether they should take that risk
on or not so you know that's it that's a
difficult one and then the next level up
from that might be someone who's running
a fund uh on real estate and that person
has an enormous amount of capital
leverage and they're dealing with lots
and lots of developers and maybe they're
buying huge amounts of houses and
inventory one level above that might be
a company like opendoor that's writing
code
to buy inventory of and carrying a
massive book of houses so you see each
level how increasing leverage increasing
accountability increasing specific
knowledge adding in money based leverage
on top of labor-based leverage adding in
code-based leverage on top of money and
labor uh
allows you to actually create something
bigger and bigger and get closer and
closer to owning all the upside and not
just being paid a salary so generally
when you're working in life yes you
start as a salaried employee but you
essentially want to work your way up
this stack that i just talked about to
try and get to higher and higher
leverage accountability and specific
knowledge and the combination of those
over a long enough period of time with
the magic of compound interest will make
you wealthy
how do you work your way up i mean i
hate to say it but you just do really
good work for a long time and it is
thankless until people recognize you
it's the nature of these things that
nobody recognizes you for a long time
and then everybody recognizes you all at
once like all the opportunities hit you
at once
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you